être qui aurait pu prédire une telle
image il y a à peine un nom celle d'un
ancien humoriste ukrainien devenu malgré
lui le président d'un pays en guerre
ovationné par le Congrès américain tout
de kaki vêtu la visite sous haute
sécurité de vous le dis merci à
Washington et sans contestin moment
d'histoire reçu à la Maison Blanche par
Joe Biden puis par les élus au Capitole
le président ukrainien a défendu son
armée et en juin les États-Unis à
poursuivre et à renforcer encore l'aide
militaire à son pays
contre toute attente malheur et
tristesse l'Ukraine n'est pas tombé
l'Ukraine est en vie et elle se bat
nous n'avons aucune crainte et le monde
ne doit pas en avoir
l'Ukraine remportera la victoire
ce qui nous donne du courage et inspire
le monde entier
les États-Unis remportent cette victoire
et vous avez réussi à unir la communauté
internationale à protéger la liberté et
le droit international
les Européens remporté cette victoire et
c'est pourquoi l'Europe est plus forte
et plus indépendante que jamais
les tyrans russes ont perdu tout
contrôle sur nous